the Joe Rogan experience I remember I
tested for a reality show on Food
Network and they had me unset for about
of an hour and they were like yeah this
is not I said I said like three things
into the camera and they go none of this
will ever this is not gonna work what is
this a well they were just basically
like it was called hot spots and they're
like tell us what you think a hot spot
is well it's a real cool hot spot now
just like a hot spot is when I try to
get into it the maitre d tells me to
kill myself and then they go okay well
let's do the joke again but let's not
say kill yourself I'm like well that's
the joke right so they're like just
maybe say something like when I try to
get in they say no and I'm like you but
that's not funny so then we just tried
to work around at a bunch of different
ways and I would just keep saying things
and you could tell they were just
getting frustrated networks like Food
Network love the idea of comedians to
like we love the idea of having a
comedian come in to spice it up and then
wouldn't they get a real comedian
they're like we don't want that well
then why but ironic an I am with like
three tracks yeah it wasn't like a real
down the middle
goofy and a lot of lane changes I was
making fun of like we had all the
archetypes of the food network like we
had the fat southern woman they were
supposed to be Paula Deen and she came
in she's like have you ever had a
redneck real cheese and I said this
woman's gonna explode on set and and I
because they said you can be playful
with each other so I said this woman's
gonna explode on set and they go oh do I
wait a man I'm like you said we could be
playful
we had the Asian woman who was like she
just talked about wellness she was like
out we just I want to be whole and I
want to be one and I wouldn't be
wellness and then so every you know you
had the guy fieri like you know there's
a million chefs that think they're
Bourdain they think they're profound but
in reality they're just making [ __ ]
grilled cheese and they have tattoos but
other than that you know so we had a
bunch of those chefs who were like I'm a
hard-partying I've seen it all I've seen
it all I've worked on the line it's a
shut up
you've made me Oh can't Dean with with
Kitchen Confidential he changed what a
chef is he changed what a chef is but
most chefs are not that and the reality
is is like you hear people now that
travel around the country and they think
that they're like and I love board
Bourdain at provincial but sometimes
Bourdain show was interesting because
like he'd be sitting with a family in
Turkey and they'd be like well we
haven't seen our daughter in two days
and
know where she is revolution and then
they would it would be like and then you
would like they would start talking
about hummus and I'd be like what
happened you talk like what's going on
like why are we talking about figs right
now there's a revolution happening this
whole idea that like food like I think
Bourdain was a genius but the people
that have succeeded him haven't done it
well is anybody doing it that way where
they're traveling around the Gordon
Ramsay they were talking about him doing
something but the backlash was
immediately light and fierce yeah
because people were thinking that he was
gonna try to replace Bourdain right if
he stays in his wheelhouse is Hell's
Kitchen and doing all those shows that
he did before everybody would've been
fine right but they were like hey [ __ ]
he's gonna come up come at ya you need
to I mean imagine doing no reservations
now or what is the the new show
what was it much announced or no was
imagine it's like parts unknown with
your host Tim Dylan now it would not
work and I would say it would be thought
it would come get you ya know be a
problem and it's also like he was a
really brilliant guy like most people
that like you're like all were eating
food and learning about the culture it's
like you're really not you're just
having dinner he actually was he was
because he was curious and interested
but most people that are like that or
it's just a lot of people pretentious
yeah and they think that they're
learning about the culture through food
we're learning about the culture through
dining and it's like you're not really
you're eating in a resort you're not
going anywhere outside of the resort
because you you will get harpoon so
you're eating in a resort and then
there's a black SUV that takes you back
to the airport like bulletproof its
bulletproof armed guards flanking you
and he's you know the one time that you
didn't have that I was on the
Impractical Jokers cruise which they
have a cruise they do a cruise and
they're they're great guys and a bunch
of comics came on to entertain people
that were waiting to see them people
waiting to see them but we would come on
and go hey and they would they would
think it was them and they'd be like
okay that's this guy and there were fun
audiences and everything but then the
cruise would dock and you would go to
this little town in Mexico that was like
clearly didn't exist it was just like
you know yeah all these cruise lines had
bought just a certain amount of
beachfront and made it a town yeah and
they do this he was called Costa Maya
they literally do this and you know you
would walk onto this Beach and then
literally they would
like drive you to the little tourist
area but you would just see people
running around with bare feet roosters I
mean it was like you would drive through
like literal in crazy poverty and you
felt horrible because you were just on a
boat that had 30 chefs right you were
just on this disgusting boat with a
24-hour buffet where people are gorging
themselves and then you go to this
island where like people's bones are
protruding out of their body so it's so
it's a weird it's a weird thing when you
mix those worlds of like food travel and
you know education
[Applause]